- [Instructor] Gibbs Free
Energy is symbolized by G
and change in Gibbs Free Energy
is symbolized by delta G.
And the change in free energy, delta G,
is equal to the change
in enthalpy, delta H,
minus the temperature in Kelvin,
times the change in entropy, delta S.
When delta G is less than zero,
a chemical or physical process is favored
in the forward direction.
Therefore, we say that the forward process
is thermodynamically favored.
As an example, if we look at a reaction
where reactants turn into products,
if delta G is less than zero,
the forward reaction as
thermodynamically favored,
meaning the reaction will go to the right
to make more products.
Textbooks will often use
the word spontaneous.
So, when delta G is less than zero,
the reaction would be spontaneous
in the forward direction.
When delta G is greater than zero,
the chemical or physical process
is favored in the reverse direction.
Therefore, the forward process
is not thermodynamically favored.
Going back to our reaction, as an example,
if delta G is greater than zero,
that means the reverse
reaction is favored,
which favors the formation
of the reactants.
For this example,
textbooks will often say that the reaction
is non-spontaneous in
the forward direction,
which means the reaction is spontaneous
in the reverse direction.
And when delta G is equal to zero,
the chemical or physical
process is at equilibrium.
So, for our chemical reaction,
if delta G is equal to zero,
the reaction is at equilibrium
and the concentration
of reactants and products
will remain constant.
When we see delta G with
a superscript naught,
we're talking about the
change in Gibbs Free Energy
when substances are in
their standard states.
By convention, the standard
state of a solid or liquid
is referring to the pure
solid or the pure liquid
under a pressure of one atmosphere.
The standard state of a gas
is referring to the pure gas
at a pressure of one atmosphere.
And the standard state of a solution
is talking about a one
Mueller concentration.
If our substances are
in the standard state,
we can add a superscript to the
equation that we saw before.
So, we could calculate delta G naught,
the standard change in free energy
by getting the standard change
in enthalpy and from that,
subtracting the absolute
temperature in Kelvin,
times the standard change in entropy.
When the substances are
in their standard states,
delta G naught is equal to delta G.
Therefore, we can say
that if delta G naught
is less than zero,
if we're talking about a reaction,
the reaction is thermodynamically favored
in the forward direction.
And if delta G naught
is greater than zero,
we could say the reaction is
not thermodynamically favored
in the forward direction.
Next, let's calculate delta G naught
for a chemical reaction.
And for our reaction,
let's look at the synthesis
of hydrogen fluoride gas
from hydrogen gas and fluorine gas.
Our goal is to calculate delta G naught
for this reaction at 25 degrees Celsius.
Delta H naught for this
reaction at 25 degrees Celsius
is equal to negative 537.2
kilojoules per mole of reaction.
And delta S naught for this
reaction at 25 degrees Celsius
is equal to 13.7 joules per
Kelvin mole of reaction.
The next step is to plug
everything into our equation.
So, to calculate delta
G naught of reaction,
we need to plug in delta
H naught of reaction,
delta S naught of reaction,
and also the temperature in Kelvin.
So, we can plug in delta
H naught of reaction
into our equations.
That's negative 537.2
kilojoules per mole of reaction.
Next, we think about the temperature.
The temperature is 25 degrees Celsius
and we need to convert that into Kelvin.
So, 25 plus 273 is equal to 298 Kelvin.
Next we think about delta S naught,
and here we have to be careful with units
because delta H naught was in kilojoules
and delta S naught was
given to us in joules.
So, one approach is
to convert delta S naught into kilojoules
per Kelvin mole of reaction.
So, we could divide this number by 1,000,
or we could move the decimal
place three to the left.
So, 13.7 joules per
Kelvin mole of reaction
is equal to 0.0137 kilojoules
per Kelvin mole of reaction.
Looking at our units,
Kelvin will cancel out
and that gives us kilojoules
per mole of reaction.
So, when we do the math, delta
G naught for this reaction
is equal to negative 541.3
kilojoules per mole of reaction.
Since delta G naught for
this reaction is negative,
that means the forward reaction
is thermodynamically favored.
So, we can think about the
reactants coming together
to make the products.
And since we calculated delta G naught,
the reactants and products
are in their standard states.
So, what our calculation
means is if we had a mixture
of hydrogen gas, fluorine gas,
and hydrogen fluoride gas,
and we're at a temperature
of 25 degrees Celsius,
and each gas had a partial
pressure of one atmosphere,
the forward reaction is
thermodynamically favored,
which means the hydrogen
gas and fluorine gas
would come together to make
more hydrogen fluoride.